más tarde y miles de personas en riesgo
de terminar en la calle la mayoría
latinos y afrodescendientes este sábado
termina la prohibición de desalojo de
viviendas en el estado de nueva york
funcionarios públicos se unieron el
viernes a una manifestación para exigir
su extensión no puedes permitir que una
moratoria caduque en pleno invierno y
durante el auge de omicron todas esas
cosas no pueden suceder
si termina ahora sabemos que decenas de
miles de mujeres y niños de color en
nuevayork van a ser desalojados por sus
caseros van a terminar en las calles
se estima que 500 mil neoyorquinos
necesitan ayuda para la vivienda desde
el inicio la pandemia ha habido más de
81 mil solicitudes de desalojo pese a la
prohibición cuántas personas más tienen
que quedarse en la calle porque los
propietarios codiciosos se aprovechan de
un sistema que aumentan los precios
la gobernadora katy winn recordó la
existencia de un programa de alivio de
alquiler programa que sin embargo ya no
tiene fondos económicos el alcalde de
nueva york eric adams pidió el miércoles
ayuda a washington wind y necesitamos
que el gobierno federal dé un paso al
frente y ayude a los neoyorquinos a
mantener su casa
la medida que paraliza a los desahucios
fue implementada en marzo de 2020 cuando
nueva york se convirtió en epicentro del
cob y 19
la moratoria ha sido extendida en
distintas ocasiones mientras los
activistas piden que se apruebe el
proyecto de ley de desalojo por buena
causa
esta legislación reforzaría la
protección de los inquilinos a la hora
de renovar contratos limitaría el
aumento del precio y requeriría la orden
de un juez para obtener un desalojo